my parents always say I remind the my
uncle Steve Steve doesn't have a wife a
car or consistent hot water but what he
does have is a bald spot now I'm nervous
at the bald spot runs in the family he's
starting to noticing he was losing his
hair in his 20s today I'm doing
something proactive he decided to rock a
new look the LA freeway it's not so much
a hairstyle as it is a car wreck the
crop circle the truth may be out there
but your dignity is not the out bro I
teach math by day and cry alone by night
the honeycomb over Wow huh the boy going
a middle-aged man band when you look
less like a sexy pop star and more like
the creepy guy who signed him when he
was 12 the away at a business conference
cthulhu at the dumpster genie I woke
vagon direct high school musicals in a
school that cares way more about its
football program don't procrastinate
like wild with Steve deserve to lose
your hair do something now like use
rogaine school to glee proven to regrow
hair so you don't have to get as
creative as my uncle Steve seriously
guys get rogaine I'm in horrific pain
right now